addiction is compulsive behavior despite
negative consequences and it's really
important to start by defining addiction
because for a long time we really
defined it very poorly we used to think
that addiction was needing a substance
to function and what that resulted in
was that cocaine was not addictive
because cocaine does not produce
physical withdrawal that is noticeable
you may be cranky and irritable and
crave cocaine but you won't be puking
and shaking and have the classic
symptoms that you would see with alcohol
or heroin withdrawal so cocaine wasn't
addictive then crack came and we
realized that defining addiction in that
way not only harms people by telling
them that cocaine is not addictive it
also harms pain patients because people
who take opioids daily for pain will
develop physical dependence but they are
not addicted unless they have compulsive
behavior despite negative consequences I
see addiction as a learning disorder and
the reason that I see it that way is
because the biology of addiction unfolds
in the developmental context over time
and that means that a huge amount of
variables come into it not only genes
and you know early environment but also
culture your family the way you
interpret your own experience so it yeah
it becomes very complicated pretty
quickly
addiction is a learning disorder because
it can't occur without learning you have
to learn to associate the drug with some
kind of relief or pleasure and you need
to do that repeatedly over time before
you can become addicted this is why a
baby can't be addicted because a baby
who is born with physical dependence on
something like heroin doesn't know
whether it needs a diaper change or just
wants mommy or wants heroin and it
certainly can't go out and score despite
negative consequences so while that's
another reason that it's really
important to distinguish between
physical dependence and a dick
so the learning is involved where you
learn that this works to fix a problem
and you basically then fall in love with
the substance and once you've fallen in
love with somebody or something
you will persist despite negative
consequences in order to sustain that
relationship because the biology is
going to tell you that your life depends
on this it basically acts in a brain
region that is involved in survival and
reproduction and those are the two
fundamental purposes of biology so that
creates really really strong cravings
and it changes your priorities
tremendously and we don't really think
about that when somebody falls in love
and gets married and has a kid we think
that's very normal and it is very normal
on but if you notice how people behave
around love affairs whether licit or
illicit they will tend to put that first
and they will do things that they might
not otherwise do in pursuit of that and
you can certainly see that when people
have affairs where they will lie etc in
order to overcome addiction you need to
figure out what purpose the addiction
was serving in my case I had a lot of
depression and I was very I had a lot of
difficulties connecting with people I
was also sort of overwhelmed by my
senses and emotions a lot of the time
and opioids turned that down very nicely
so I needed to sort of figure out you
know what was up and deal with those
issues in order to you know be healthy
and comfortable in recovery and that's
going to be different for different
people because they are going to have
different issues that they are
medicating with the drugs
I think psychedelics may be very useful
in the treatment of addiction but they
are certainly not a cure I think it's
very important to keep in mind that
insight alone does not change behavior
and with drugs like I began which seems
to help relieve opioid withdrawal
it's all well and good if you you know
have a trip and then you are no longer
physically dependent on the drug but if
you then go back to the same environment
and you haven't made changes that are
going to allow you to cope in a
different way
you will probably relapse and end up
back in the same situation so while it
could be very useful to gain insight on
what's going on with you via
psychedelics this idea that there will
be a sort of one-shot cure for addiction
has been a tremendous problem in the
field for a really long time and I think
it's really important for the people who
are promoting the use of psychedelics in
addiction treatment not to over promise
addiction is a very human problem and
this is often why people propose and
some people benefit from a spiritual
solution to it that's not to say we
should treat medicine and medical
conditions with spirituality but the
reality is that addiction and depression
and a lot of other mental illnesses do
often involve struggling with
existential questions and so it is not
going to be the case that you can just
put a brain implant in and addiction
will go away without a big chunk of
yourself going away you know the Chinese
are horribly experimenting with this
horrific brain surgery where they oblate
ie burn out the nucleus accumbens which
is basically the brain region that
provides pleasure and motivation and
they think that this is actually going
to cure addiction of course what happens
is you get people who are just anhedonic
and who relapse because you know now
they have even less so you know this
idea that like we could use a drug that
will block the effects of the drug of
choice is generally misguided because
the problem isn't the drug of choice the
problem is why you need that drug and
why those drugs appeal to you and why
you are trying to get out why you were
trying to escape and what you need in
your life in order to feel comfortable
safe and productive so I don't think
that there will be future weird cures
like that but what I do think is
interesting about the future of drugs is
that we can make better drugs part of
the reason that prohibition is
collapsing at the moment is because of
what are called new psychoactive
substances or legal hides and basically
you can make a new recreational drug by
sort of tweaking molecules of the other
ones and it will be technically legal
because it hasn't been made illegal and
what this reveals is that our system for
making drugs illegal is completely
irrational and based on you know 19th
century prejudices has nothing to do
with science and if we apply science to
this problem and look at well people are
always going to want to alter their
consciousness in some ways how do we
reduce the harm associated with this how
do we create drugs or medications that
will allow people to feel safe and
comfortable in the world but not be so
distracting or problematic that they
will not be able to feel you know
connect with other people they won't be
so you know out of it so I think the
future of drugs is better drugs I don't
think the future of drugs will be or you
know you could virtual reality these
kinds of things could all be very
interesting but I think that so long as
people ask the question why am I here
and so long as people need each other to
love and connect we are going to have
people who want to find ways to make
that work better